an iconic aircraft previously consigned
to the great scrapyard in the sky
is now making a triumphant return
it's back the airbus a380 super jumble
is taking to the skies again thanks to a
resurgence in air traffic the world's
biggest passenger aircraft has been
pulled out of retirement by many
airlines including emirates and british
airways and for many the return of their
entire a380 fleets can't happen fast
enough
dubai-based emirates has by far the
world's biggest a380 fleet followed by
singapore airlines in third place comes
lufthansa even the germans are planning
to deploy some of their super jumbo
planes again
australia's qantas and british airways
round up the top five list for most a380
aircraft
lufthansa parked many aircraft in spain
when the covet 19 pandemic ground air
traffic to a halt the a380 was supposed
to be retired for good fought too big
unprofitable and bad for the planet but
times have clearly changed with
lufthansa now planning a380 voyages for
summer 2023
let's speak to aviation journalist
andreas spear to a little get a little
bit more about this because um it seems
a bit strange to me andreas the problems
with the a380 haven't gone away it's
still got those four big engines that
need lots and lots of fuel and it's
still massive it's still difficult to
fill as difficult as it was before the
pandemic so uh
why are airlines willing to look past
those problems and reinstate it
i think they're just in urgent need of
capacity and that as fast as possible so
the a380 fleet that was already kind of
mothballed and long-term storage around
europe and elsewhere where the easiest
solution and as you just rightly said
there's a huge surge of demand right now
and it's also foreseeable that that will
last until the next season starts so
actually as it takes quite some time to
reactivate them they'll just be ready in
time for the early summer season meaning
spring 2023.
yes as you mentioned it's it's not an
immediate thing it's not really going to
offer any relief to the problems that
we're seeing right now at airports is it
but why does it take so long i mean i
think lufthansa is not expecting to
bring them back in like you say until
the middle of next year
yes it takes a full nine months
lufthansa ceo carson told me recently to
reactivate an a380 from
so-called deep storage and deep storage
means the aircraft is kept in a
air-worthy condition on the ground but
still it takes a long time to kind of
get it run engines run up and kind of
get really the technical details and
checks being done as a huge aircraft
after all on the other hand also there's
a pilot shortage lufthansa has just kept
14 a380 captains current and that's the
reason the allied now will base its
newly revamped a380s from in munich
airport because that's where the a350s
the more modern aircraft is based and
there their pilots the a350 pilots can
easily be retrained and cross-trained to
also simultaneously fly the a380 that's
the reason for pilots and reactivation
in technical terms
so there's a clearly renewed uh demand
for for a large aircraft like this but
airbus isn't making them anymore and the
the jumbo jet the 747s also not being
made anymore so
where are they supposed to get these big
enough aircraft if they need them the
airlines
yeah that's a very big concern of some
islands especially emirates and
yesterday at the farmer air show in
england there was a high-level
panel with the head of yata the yata is
the uh
schedule association and sir tim clark
the emirates president and they both
agreed and it's really a big omission
it's almost like a sin uh not to look at
all at the moment
what the next generation in big aircraft
could be
boeing currently has problems delivering
on its largest aircraft that's in
production right now the triple 7-9 and
that's also one of the reasons the a380
is coming back as a stop-gap measure but
it's really a big fault of the industry
emirates says at least that nobody right
now looks at any big replacement like in
the midterm to long-term future
wow
nothing in the pipeline andrea spade
thanks a lot for joining us
thank you very much